herr kollege schnürschuh
ist die alte schule schnell war bin ich
träume hat meine wohnung raus welche
bank umziehen und in den drei monaten wo
ich dann zurück nach hamburg ziehen
meine kölner wohnung umgebaut
hier kann nicht siehst du auf aus köln
frank ist das krass wie irgendwo unten
schwimmt und zitrone oben oder
bio schon heftig
dass er keine auskunft über seinen
status oder
bestimmte
txt
msn sie uns also dass sie zwischen
stimmt das haben jetzt schon runter
geräumt und komme ich jetzt sehr hoch
was machen die beiden sorgt die glanztag
bier kommen
ich habe selber bestimmt weil ich am
meisten rechte habe das virus namens da
holen für dem konto
ich bin dabei aber ihr müsst euch um den
kümmern
kommt das richtig anwenden so kleinen
ausgaben aber
was haltet ihr von der samstag haben in
dem podcast
jetzt wirklich
[Musik]
kaufen
wofür nimmst du jetzt den scheiß wagen
samstag ist kleiner ist ein handy das
ist ja alles so welt hier sind wir also
die hegewald ihre kleinen mäuschen
darauf eine bestimmte
jetzt die polizei konsum aufmachen die
bude weg das sind keine schildkröten an
wirklich ich bin profi hat gut acht
jahre namens gekauft jetzt weißt ja
lexikon auswendig meine worte hat eine
schlange drehleiter
da ist doch eigentlich das grüne hier
kann ein solches werk bartagamen 240
euro kauft und ramsthal
chefin der vogelspinne sondern komplett
falsch lassen sondern diese gefehlt
wie heißt das ding noch machen
[Musik]
habt ihr die wehren sich mit tiefer
vertragen 990 euro kosten sondern wird
halt hier als besuch teurer noch gar
nicht ins spiel und lag plötzlich viel
engagement für seine sport werken die
haben es ja hier einfach über zwei
etagen
er hat so self gezeigt dass ich filme
sie sogar schon flaschen becher gekauft
zu beginn habe ich dann einfach
ausgedacht weil sie den einkaufswagen
holen wollte für ein freies haben wir
zwei weitere karten sowohl wir sind bei
300 euro die dachten halt wir gehen hier
einkaufen und hamster und jetzt haben
wir jetzt so viel kram gegen die am
start wir wollen keinen zu aufmachen
sondern hat sich jetzt namenstag gekauft
da können wir ja wohl meinen die hat
einen vogel
das ist alles nicht
machen jetzt hier schon mal so ein
kleines unboxing aus dem reifen
überhaupt gut geht es los
einfach ein kleintier pass hat machte er
zum zeitpunkt der übergabe des tieres
sind folgende der bereiche
augenscheinlich gesund augen ohren
baubereich after
habe ich fand es nur weil mein auto
entweder der käfig rein passt oder harry
und ich fahre jetzt mit ihr
soll ist leise an machen oder was hatte
ich schieb autor einfach nach hause wir
hoffen dass er überlebt hat bis jetzt
klar wir machen da jetzt schon druck
aber die waren jetzt richtig gut geht
die show bewerben das beste gekauften
rund um die uhrzeit und wir sehen uns
jetzt wieder
richtig läuft dann auch zu zeigen
routiniert aus havanna wieder zu mir
kommen nur weil er schon herzen
hauptsache die ist jetzt auch noch vor
uns da alte
gerät jetzt ein ganz kurzes wohnung
aufbauend ist aufgefallen dass der krieg
ich einfach schon zusammengekommen ist
doch keine time life science ist
mittlerweile
der akku von meiner kamera ist leider
leer gegangen erster blogger deswegen
ziehe mich jetzt haben dem handy weiter
und wir haben das gehege käfig aquaro
wir uns bereits jetzt auf jeden fall
fertig gestellt der kleine verbuddelt
sich ja schon die ganze zeit entdeckt
alles so ein bisschen ist glaube ich
ziemlich happy darüber wer menschen
essen trinken und sammelt zum baden
baden den sand was das auch immer so
denkt auch er selbst bei am ende
glaube reif geht durch die decke weil
reihe von spots werden sie follower aber
ich sage um 3 oder
[Gelächter]
was
aber das doch überhaupt nichts
sogar perspektive wäre mir alle meine
nachbarn jeweils eine flasche rotwein
und oropax in so eine tüte gepackt und
einen zettel den uns arbeiten infos und
das ist einfach nur typisch einmal nicht
sind dabei hier die ganzen smileys
abzunehmen
es ist schon sehr traurig irgendwie
[Musik]
wir sind fertig sie nicht partie
haben wir uns anders kochen einfach
gerade fischstäbchen kartoffelpüree vor
uns und haben ja gerade geschrieben die
sonne mutter essl ist in 15 minuten
schießt du dich schon jetzt zuerst mal
live zu sehen
wir klingeln jetzt kurz bestseller und
forschen hallo
hallo wer montag
hallo hallo der himmel ist blau sowie
sagen wir in der portokasse auch in
kraft getreten und hier mit komplett
neuen schuhen danke das den fonds
mittagessen gekocht hat er jetzt ein
überdimensionales labyrinth eine brücke
hamsterrad das 40 mal so groß wie ralf
essen badewanne trinken und eine
kokosnuss und dann allerdings gerettet
haben gesagt haben ja der braucht platz
und so zum buddeln derartigen
[Musik]
popstars folge vorbei
wie wird sich die heutige folge
beschreiben
du musst wieder ins regal
mcfit haben wir nicht
ich würde dem loch an der stelle jetzt
glaube ich auch endet meine lieben
freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat der
lask einen daumen hoch da abonniert main
kanal und klickt auf die wiesn